you ever made a stupid purchase of
purchase you regret
well i do own a time machine
you know it's it you know i don't know
if i regret it the guy who sold it to me
eventually went on to say that i was an
alien when i tried to ask him i couldn't
get back to 1952. he said you're an
alien i know you you're an alien oh so
he said you [ __ ] up yeah did you
really buy a time machine i did yeah
tell me how that was so there's a
there's a gentleman by the name of art
bell he had a radio talk radio show and
i know that guy and so i would listen to
it all the time and there was a guest a
great steven gibbs and he had created
the hyper dimensional resonator which
was a time machine
and he was talking through the entire
process of what it's like to go through
time and all these different things and
and and i was like this is fascinating
so he was talking about getting the time
machine catalog i was going to order the
catalog
and then at the very end of the show i
wrote down the address and then when at
the very end of the show was like how
much is it was 375 dollars and so i
fedexed him a check i'm like i need one
and 370 for attenuation oh and it showed
up and it's like you know why because he
built it probably in the 1800s that's
like five million dollars it's inflation
yeah and look and it he in in our first
conversation was amazing he was like
okay couple things i got to warn you
about if you clean your garage you might
come back and it's dirty again stuff
like that maybe someone you knew in the
past died and i'm like this you know me
and him talk so casually about time
travel after i got it right that i'm
was freaked out a little bit like damn i
don't i don't know if i'm ready to
travel through time you know and i you
know of course i asked what do you think
like could you go back and get lottery
numbers he's oh
when you go through the zero vector
point and you go through god i was gonna
say you're never gonna want number
you're you're never gonna want anything
material ever again then i was really
freaked out right and
um
you know i laid it on my chest
travel through time and i just passed
out
so i don't know it could be look this
amazing life that i have right now at
the howie mandel does stuff show with
the kids and friends like this could be
time travel
did you get in the machine no it's you
just it's literally like a box that you
sit on the side and you put like a phone
cord around your head and you put like a
magnet on your chest how did you know
you weren't going to get stopped
like look i was young
did you pass out i did i was drunk
though when i did the tried to do the
first one yeah
he just came up with a new name for your
show what's that howie mandel does stuff
with kids and friends
[Laughter]
you know what that sounds like something
you can get arrested yeah never mind you
know i bought uh i bought 2 400 square
feet once yeah
and and i regret it because it's so hard
to find shoes
[Laughter]
[Music]